ps ça ne vous servira peut-être pas pour
rentrer ce soir si vous avez abusé de la
dive bouteille mais renault vient de
présenter en avant première un service
d'un système de guidage des voitures en
temps réel c'est le fruit de huit années
de recherches et carminat c'est le nom
de ce système sera testé en grandeur
nature dans les rues de paris
il devrait couvrir toutes les grandes
villes françaises d'ici fin 95
démonstration de niffer des dominique
boucher avec carminat le nouveau système
en temps réel d'informations du trafic
de village développé par renault et tdf
l'ère de la voiture en qui bouche on est
du trajet planifié sans stress est
arrivé tester grandeur nature à paris et
dans les hauts-de-seine
ce guidage dynamique par ordinateur de
bord mis au point après huit ans de
recherche sera commercialisé dès 1996 à
des prix de 2500 à 20 mille francs
suivant les versions choisi qu'il ya au
départ les informations routières qui
correspondent aux attentes principales
mais également les places disponibles
dans les grands parkings les autres
l'utilisation sont plus pour les
professionnels les gens qui passent de
très longues heures à circuler dans la
région parisienne dans des banlieues qui
ne qui ne connaissent pas et qui évite
de perdre du temps à tourner en rond à
éventuellement se perdre
une fois que la digue à sion de la
destination et précisé le véhicule vous
conduit jusqu'à la porte de votre votre
destination expérimenté sur l'île de
france sur les axes paris lille londres
et stuttgart lyon méditerranée
le système à diffusion numérique rds
sera utilisable après péage d'une
redevance de 800 francs par an ce
nouveau procédé permettra aux 35 % de
voitures assurant les 20 millions de
déplacements quotidiens en ile-de-france
d'endiguer les embouteillages de réguler
le trafic
en choisissant le meilleur itinéraire en
ville une expérience qui devrait
déboucher sur une couverture européenne
en 98